gas prices are rising and we know that
it affects your life if you're spending
more for gas you have less to spend on
other things so we started the campaign
in conjunction with conoco to help gift
you a good day we'll take a look now at
how i surprised one lucky customer and
gifted him a very very good morning
i met arturo at conoco on east lake mead
how expensive is it for you on a regular
basis
everywhere i go gas has been going up i
remember filling up with almost like 30
to get
for a whole tank for a little small car
but now it's like 40 50. arturo says he
does what he has to do to make ends meet
just have to lower down my budget on
everything else he also searches for the
best gas prices i look around but it
looks like everywhere is going up like
there's nowhere to find it you know
then he got a big surprise you're in
luck channel 8 and conoco is here to try
and help you and gift you a good day
we're going to help pay for your gas
arturo there you go
congratulations gifting you a good day
gonna help pay for your gas today buddy
thanks a lot thank you man i appreciate
it so much
he was caught off guard
slightly had a great time surprising him
though you never know when you might be
next keep an eye out for the good day
team and watch good day las vegas which
is what we are on right now same time on
thursday we'll gift someone else a very
very good day